I'm trying to build people up I'm trying
to armor their mind I'm trying to get
them the belief because this world we
live in is tough it will beat you down
the world and the life that we live in
is the ultimate competitor it will try
to take you out it will find your
weakness and it will just Hammer you if
I can help you build belief build
confidence to the point where nothing
can hurt you because you know exactly
who you are
David Goggins welcome to the show hey
man I appreciate you having me brother
thank you thank you for being here where
have you been for the last four years
you've been jumping out of helicopters
and fighting fires and what have you
been doing well I did that last year
right I guess this year I did that but
I've just I just do me you know I'm out
there running working out and uh just
trying to find out more of what this is
all about trying to find out more what
I'm all about so that takes me getting
away
you know I'm not about even doing these
podcasts man so not nothing against you
but um I'm not about all this stuff I'm
not one that likes to hear himself talk
a lot
um about action and action means
less talking and more doing so that's
where I've been what is that smoke
jumping stuff so basically it's um you
know about Wildland firefighting about
when the forest has fires
there's a lot of times there's roads and
there's access to get there so these you
know whether it be a
um hot shot crew or whatever these
different Crews who come in by vehicle
they can get into the fire that way what
a smoke jumper is is you can't get a
vehicle into that place
it is a spot where it's tight there's no
vehicles there's no access
so they'll send us in there smoke
jumpers jump out of airplanes and we'll
land in these really tight small Drop
Zones with all of our gear and we'll put
the fire out
how do you take Walter in we jump out so
everything is hang on you're jumping out
of a airplane parachute with
backpacks of water like a camel pack
type thing so we'll jump out we'll have
this it's called a ditty pack and it and
it sits in you know it sits like by your
waist you know yep on your legs area
when you jump out and that has a lot of
your gear but what happens is once you
jump out the aircraft would go lower and
will push out
all the rest of your gear your water
pumps oh and that'll get air dropped in
with its own little parachutes right
right so a lot of our main gear gets
dropped into us and then we're out there
for several days until the fire is put
out by us and only us
that's insane it's insane yeah why'd you
do that
well when I left the military
um you're I'm always looking for more
I'm always looking for what's the next
thing for myself how can I grow
and that right there was the next thing
for me you know I didn't want to sit
back and you know just enjoy my
retirement for the military that's
there's there's no growth in that so I
decided to go out and do this
so you jump out of an airplane with a
team you get your kit also parachuted
out of the back you're now in the middle
of an area where there's no Evac there's
no vehicles that can come and get you
there's a fire you need to put the fire
out and you don't stop until you're done
that's it
sometimes there is a way to get out but
a lot of times it's just you know if
someone gets hurt on the jump a lot of
times we have to build like cut down a
bunch of trees so a helicopter can come
in land and get them out so we are the
only access
we have to save ourselves
so a lot of times we are the team to get
us in and to get us out what was the
longest
Mission exercise I think the longest one
I did was seven days
so and what's the sort of daily routine
are you sleeping do you get much sleep
at all no not really so what happens is
and the thing about being in Canada so I
do this out of uh out of British
Columbia
so what happens is there's a lot of
daylight
so when I'm out there man there's a lot
of daylight in the middle of the summer
when it's hot when you've got tons of
right okay that's right so there's not
much there's not much dark so you're
basically working a lot of hours so and
then when it gets dark you're actually
working through the night time and then
you get a little you know you get a
little rest and you wake up and you add
it again
and then when the fire is out you Patrol
the fire make sure there's no more hot
spots make sure everything is black and
wet because we we literally wet the
whole area down so there's no hot spots
and then that's all done
we'll demo which means we'll clean up
all the stuff all our hoses you know
we'll we'll pack up all our stuff and
then we'll we'll get out of there did
you ask to be paid for this I
I get about I think the the pay is about
12 to 15 bucks an hour
so it was funny about it man like when I
first started doing this job
um
people
didn't know that you know I'm actually
successful in business
and then it realized that I was like
basically turned down millions of
dollars to do this job and they can
continue thinking it to make 15 bucks a
month to make 15 bucks an hour so yeah
but you know like I said for me the the
whole money part of it it's it's not
what it's about
I'm all about that growth and that
growth isn't in these massive paychecks
for speaking to corporations stuff like
that the growth for me is in that 12 to
15 an hour when you're out there and
it's like
20 you know 20 degrees and you're
freezing your ass off and you're
thinking you know what I don't need to
be here anymore
and you start questioning yourself while
you're here and there's a lot of growth
in that
why did you decide to release another
book what Was undone with the first one
well the first one was basically
um a bachelor's degree
with the mind is how I look at it and no
one knew who I was so this is the book
never finished is the book that I wanted
to come out first
but how am I going to get so deep into
something when no one knows who the hell
I am
so first I have to give you some
backstory on who the hell David Goggins
is some credentials that's it and so I
got some basic credentials out there
and now I can dive in more because most
people think I'm just some good animal
who runs and yells and just says [ __ ]
[ __ ] all the time and that's
nowhere near the truth that's maybe what
they see in a one minute video and
that's what people believe but there's a
lot of thought behind a person being a
born loser
becoming who I am today you'll just wake
up and just Rocky the [ __ ] you gotta
wake up and think about you know there's
a process to getting better
and that process is never finished
it's an appropriate title so one of the
things I've been thinking about is the
danger of success making you soft and
this must be something that you've
battled with over the last few years
right more money more attention more
Fame more free things if you wanted more
opportunities to go places and do stuff
with people right how have you
dealt with this battle of success not
making you soft you have to cap it
you have to learn to cap success
so what I do is like right now
I don't like doing podcasts there's a
lot of things I don't do have to do now
to get the messages out there to help
people out
and what I mean by capping success I
believe everybody should live their life
so everything that someone says in life
take it with a grain of salt
take what they give and don't be like oh
David goggin said this or whoever said
this no
do not take what I say and do exactly
what I say
so for me what makes me who I am because
my mission is very different than yours
or anybody else's
I have to go into a situation okay
I'm a guy who wants to make people
better
for people to get better I have to
continuously get better myself
for me to do that I can't just say oh I
have this resume the resume is there
forever I'm good
I have to cap My Success because for me
to help people out I can't just say I
did it once
and I'm good I have to continue to
reinvent the will of the Mind
and figure out more and more ways for
you to pull because if I have a cookie
cutter message it may hit five people
out of 25. you just failed
my message needs to be in a way where I
can hit all 25 people it needs to be
broad enough
to where all 25 people may not like the
message but they're getting something
from it and that is evolution you must
continue to evolve and you don't evolve
from me in my job unless I cap myself
somewhere and say okay you made this
much money get back to [ __ ] work
it's time to get back to work
stop hearing yourself talk get off the
podcast don't be on social media too
much cut out all the [ __ ] noise get
back to the [ __ ] mental lab because
that's where the knowledge came from so
for me I must cap myself so I can come
back with better more unique knowledge
versus the you know all that cookie
cutter knowledge that's out there
that's why people buy the books I have
because it's not cookie cutter it's real
knowledge the other thing now is when
you first started
you were a Lone Ranger right nobody
really knew who you were outside of some
obscure endurance places and half-hard
truths of these weird myths right but
now you've got people's expectations lay
it on top as well so not only have you
got to deal with success potentially
making you soft so you've got to cap
that you've got to say no to more money
and opportunities and cool people right
you've also got this extra layer of
expectation that's coming through from
other people too and I think that you
talk about change humility right in the
new book too I've got to presume that
that
fits into this equation right it fits in
big time
um and that's one big reason why I do
fight fire
because the all the knowledge for myself
comes from that place it doesn't come
from the place of success
my knowledge does not come from a place
like because for me like I built Goggins
from the ground up I was born David
Goggins David Goggins wasn't good enough
he was a scared bullied
uh abused kid who struggled in life
and that kid whenever something got
tough no matter how hard I trained
remember how ready I was
whenever something got tough for me
David Goggins the real David Goggins
would come out and he would quit
so I realized this over a period of time
so I had to build Goggins
and in that process
I have to go back to that mental lab in
that mental lab is at scratch that
mental lab isn't that trained humility
and so that's where I get better
I get better when I'm digging holes in
the ground when I'm waking up early
knowing I don't have to do these things
that's where I get better so it's
important to stay hungry it's important
to stay hungry but it's important more
to stay humble within that hunger
so while you're hungry a lot of people
are hungry
but humility is everything
what was that story about William
Crawford the janitor yeah so this guy
won the Medal of Honor
so he won the Medal of Honor and which
is the highest award in the military
and this guy went to the Air Force
Academy
and he was a janitor
and no one knew who the [ __ ] this man
was he had the highest award in all the
military for heroics
for heroics saving lives putting his
life in a line could have you know could
have been killed
and he is now basically
you know cleaning [ __ ] for young
kids
and we can all imagine how that probably
went you know there's probably some you
know a little bit of taunting here and
there and he just sat there and cleaned
the [ __ ]
so that's why he's in my trained
humility part because for this man to be
at the level he was and have that kind
of humility to go I'm a medal of honor
winner but I'm gonna put that in my
closet and I'm gonna pick up my broom
and dustpan and I'm gonna pick up you
know this Rag and clean this [ __ ] for
these young men
that right there is amazing for me man
that's that's where you grow that's
that's growth huge growth and also it
shows that he was doing his job
he was a servant
he didn't look at himself any better
than anybody else
the second you do that you totally lost
you cannot look at yourself like people
with me even
I always look at people I I know where
you are I know where because I've been
there
that's why I helped so many people out
I've I've never been above you I've
always pretty much been beneath you and
that's where my knowledge came from so I
know how to reach those people who are
in the dungeon
because I've been there so many times
speaking of getting too soft did you see
that there was a news story that came
out recently about the treatment of
seals during their selection process do
you see this yeah I saw it yeah they
were getting uh sprayed with tear gas
whilst they were on the ground and they
were made to sing Happy Birthday so that
they couldn't hold their breath while it
was happening and there was a quote from
this guy I think this type of training
is really senseless said Sven yort a
Duke University associate professor who
studies tear gas and its effects it
looks more like a form of hazing right I
see all that trust me like I said you
know
I'm not gonna sugarcoat anything
I understand that guy
I understand exactly where you're coming
from
that is your personal opinion and I
totally get that
but
there's very few people in this world
who want to do a job like that
and it takes a different kind of mindset
is it tear grass appropriate I don't
know
how hard that training is I don't expect
anybody to understand it but one percent
but the loud voices of this world are
the 99 who don't understand exactly what
you have to do that's why when I speak
and you don't understand me it's
probably a good thing because that
probably means
I'm in an area of life that you're not
in which is fine that's why I don't
judge people and this guy right here
judging that unless you've been there
and done that and you really can't speak
about it unless you're in those
situations that are so hard that takes a
special human being to get through them
I think it's the same kind of feeling
that I get when I heard about Elon Musk
telling the employees at Twitter
we're going to ask you to work harder
than you've ever worked in your life
yeah this is a place Twitter is now a
company where people can go if they want
to be in the top not Point not not one
percent of hard-working programmers and
software developers on the planet that's
right and there was everybody was up in
arms this is unbelievable we're going
back to this old version of capitalism
where the the worker is being abused and
used and thrown away what they didn't
account for is that there is a
non-insignificant cohort of people for
whom that's their dream that's right
people who want to be able to get up on
a morning having gone to bed four hours
before and can contribute to some sort
of progress that they think
this this is what I'm here for yep and
it's the same with the seals if you're
not the sort of person that is built to
go through selection
it's like speaking a different language
that's it and that's why I don't try to
convince people otherwise I understand
that why you're confused
I understand why you say things like
that I'm not saying anything bad about
that
I understand it but also what you don't
understand what you fail to understand
is the other side that you need people
like that you need the Elon musks you
need the David Goggins you need some of
these Navy Seals some of these other
people you need those people
and they don't they forget that and it
takes a very very unique
person and unique mind to do some of
these jobs that are necessary in this
world especially when we're thinking
about someone going to war right do you
want your Armed Forces to be
underprepared for the battlefield
because he didn't want to be too mean to
them in advance
that's that's the problem that's the
problem and that's a problem that I've
always had
I've always had is that right there is
that with even even some of the most
trained people in the world
fall back on that it's easy to talk
about like I said
when you go through it once
we it's a perishable skill
hardness
mental hardening mental toughness it's a
perishable skill
just because you went through some
training once and you got through it
doesn't mean it lasts [ __ ] forever
and that's where most people hated me
in my life because I realized that
you don't just say oh I got it I'm
checked off I'm good for rest of my life
that's why you have to recall you recall
on [ __ ] everything
and you definitely must recall when it
comes to the mind
that is one of the biggest
re-qualifications you must have and when
you're at that level you gotta recall
every [ __ ] day not once a year
one of the other things that you did to
stop yourself from getting soft was
running the Moab 240. yep talk me
through that experience so
um
I had to run 100 mile race and I think
it was about six years you know I had
you know some heart surgeries I had some
maybe some questioning in my mind about
I call it part-time Savage I started
kind of going through this I started
getting you know a little bit injuries a
little bit there's a little bit things
that back in the day never slowed me
down
so when I got my head on my ass and
realized that hey we have more left we
can still push harder we're not there
yet
I realized talking to a guy named
Cameron Haynes he just raised 240 mile
race
and um
I'll say I'll go is this the is this the
new level is this the new is this the
new push
so when I decided to do that race
it was in the back of my mind like man
I've really become an expert at running
100 mile races
so for me this was the new level
did 200 plus mile race and what was so
amazing about that as you probably read
in the book
I had a hard time the first time doing
it I came back and did better but
what's amazing about the human mind
is that it becomes your new Norm
like to to think that I can run 200
miles 240 miles and that becomes like
running 50.
I never thought that was possible this
is why I'm I'm always pushing that limit
because I know that within pushing these
limits there's always more
so I end up doing like almost like back
to back 200 mile runs
when the tours at Myra is 240 my race
was hard at once
it became something that was very easy
after I figured it out so that's why
that happened well you got lost on the
first one oh yeah and then you went to
bed
and woke up halfway through the night
and nudged Kesh and said how long have
we got left until the end of the race
but because you hadn't completed the
official route you couldn't go across
the official Finish Line yeah so you
ring your race
um like Paces some of whom had gone home
yep what like what what do you think
it's so three in the morning and you're
ringing people saying you know that race
that we just finished because of health
problems right let me go back and finish
it so the crazy thing about that in that
in that spot so I got lost the first
time
I got seriously sick was off course so
basically I bed down about 12 hours then
I got back in the race I was still part
of the official race now okay so the
first time I got lost I got sick got
back got lost
got back in the race after 12 hours of
being out of the race
so now I get to about 200 and some of my
miles and I'm sick as hell can't breathe
how to pulmonary edema totally jacked up
and now the doctor tells me if you get
off course now and you go to the doctor
you won't be able to come back and
finish the race
so I had to make a call like you know
what I'm pretty messed up got off
so this is where you're talking about
I'm literally laying in bed
and I'm feeling better
and
I thought honestly I swear to God I
thought that someone was speaking to me
I thought it was Jennifer
it was like you're not done yet
[ __ ]
and I'm like
what the [ __ ] is this it was actually
probably my subconscious saying get your
ass back out there
so I wake Jennifer up I'm like hey how
much time do we have into the cutoff I
know that I'm already you know dnf'd so
man what happens here I'm not going to
be an official finisher of this race
this isn't for Glory no this is now for
the fact that
you can so either you can sit here and
not and think about that for a whole
year and you come back here and do this
or you can go out there for yourself and
take some some kind of pride in knowing
that
you could and you did
so basically I wake her up how much time
left she goes something like I don't
know what it was what'd you say what
time was
like you know whatever
and half my crew had left
and there's two people there I woke them
up they were going to get on a plane I
said look
can you guys help me out I have 40 miles
to go I'm going to have Jennifer drop me
back off at the spot where I left I
don't want to finish this [ __ ] race
and I couldn't cross the finish line
because I wasn't an official finisher so
I ended up finishing on a road
on you know by by a telephone pole and
that was my official finish ended up
being like 250 miles 255 miles
but it's one of the best races of all
time because we're going through it fast
but all the [ __ ] times that I was
like this is I I'm not going back and I
went back I'm not going back and I went
back I'm not going back and I went back
it showed me even more of what we have
as as humans if we're willing to go
there and we're willing to push that
extra step and like I say you know I
always tell people a lot of people man
how do you do what you do
at the end of the day I asked myself one
question can I take one more step
and usually the answer is yes so if you
can answer that question and not take
another step
that is real failure that is real
quitting
so a lot of people can take one more
step but they choose not to I don't know
if you can take two steps
you got to answer that question after
you take the first step
but I can always take one more step so
if I choose not to that's on me and I
gotta live with that
does not LinkedIn with the one second
decision yes
yes so the one second decision is I had
to live through that one second decision
several times during this race
so this race
took me a hundred and some hours okay
and this is what people don't get
for you to finish that race even though
I dnf'd I still finished in the time
so there's a lot of pride in that
if you're a hundred and some odd hours
let me use hell week this is a perfect
example hell week's 130 hours
and 130 hours is a lot of seconds
a lot of [ __ ] seconds
and if you lose let's say you win every
second but one
you lost
it only takes one second for you to lose
the whole thing so the one second
decision is just that
you're in a situation where life is
sucking let's say you're in extreme cold
water
and your life is flashing before your
eyes every time that wave goes over your
head your thought processes
I gotta get the [ __ ] out of this water
and you're in hell week
and your hour one of 130 [ __ ] hours
it's all fun and games okay because at
the beginning of Hell Week the guns are
going off it's like a pep rally so
you're [ __ ] hyped up and your boys
are linked arms and you're getting
sprayed and it's like a [ __ ] pep
rally there's structure yelling at your
bombs are going off concussion grenades
blanks from in 60s yeah who ya [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] yeah yeah [ __ ] yeah
but then what they do is they shut that
[ __ ] off
they shut it off
all that who yah all that hype it gets
real quiet
and they March you out to that surf zone
for something called surf torture
and it's got water that Pacific Ocean is
cold as [ __ ]
so no more pep rally you're now in your
head
you're linked arms with you know your
brothers beside you you don't know if
they could be there long or not you
don't care anything about yourself
you lay back and that first wave hits
you
your mind
goes straight from hour to
all the way to hour 130. you can't
process five days of this [ __ ] you now
you're now in a [ __ ] you like I gotta
get out of here you're in fight or
flight it's cold I can't be cold this
long
and then this that one second decision
comes in
you forgot every reason why you wanted
to be there
you don't care about seals you don't
care about any of this you don't care
about fighting for your country you
don't care about that goddy gold Trident
that they put on your chair you don't
care if I need that [ __ ] no more all you
want to do is go back home you want the
warmth you may want something to eat you
want your girl to hold you all those
things of comfort are there in that one
second
and this is where people lose
so what I do in that one second because
we all think about quitting when shit's
hard
but what you have to do in that one
second is hard to process information
during pain
because that pain takes over
and you can't think rationally
you're thinking about fight or flight
save yourself that's not a rational
thought it's not a thought that's going
to get you through
hard times
most people fail that one second so what
happens what I do in that one second and
there's a bigger process to all this but
in that one second
I physically stayed in that water
because if I get out of the water I quit
so I physically stay in the water but
mentally
I'm on the [ __ ] beach with the
[ __ ] instructors and the instructors
it's cold outside so they got these
Parkers on they got their cup of [ __ ]
Joe and they're warm because they've
already been through it so now it's your
turn to go through it
so many I get back with them I'm still
in the water physically but mainly I'm
back with you I'm chilling I got my
Parker on and now I'm thinking logically
because I'm warm now mentally I'm warm
I've taken that one second
let's not quit yet guys let's [ __ ]
think about your options
where are you going to end up if you
quit this [ __ ] where are you gonna go
where are you going to say to yourself
because you know you're going to get
warm the second you get out of this
water you're gonna take a shower
and you can be warm and you could be and
in five days you could be out so I start
thinking logically
I calm my brain down because your brain
just wants to get the [ __ ] out ring the
bell put your helmet down get warm and
then you're really [ __ ]
and these are the things you have to
think about the one second decision so
that's that's all about it's about
gaining control of your mind
putting things back in the proper
perspective
and then saying
I really do want to be here
and I'm gonna have a bunch of these one
seconds through this 130 hour Journey
and I have to learn to control these
because if I fail one of these one
seconds I will not be a seal I will not
be a doctor I will not be a lawyer I
will not be whatever the [ __ ] it is so
that's how important that one second
decision is it's all about your mind
taste control you you have to say [ __ ]
you
I run this [ __ ]
and that's what that's all about
we'll get back to Goggins in one minute
but first I need to tell you about
element element is a tasty electrolyte
drink mix with everything that you need
and nothing that you don't I've replaced
my morning coffee with element every day
for over three years now and I've never
looked back it means I've optimized my
hydration my brain feels better I'm not
getting mental fog and it's helping me
to curb Cravings if I'm fasting
throughout the day even video guy Dean
uses it my favorite flavor is the orange
that in a cold glass of water upon
waking feels really really good it's a
science-backed electrolyte ratio of
sodium potassium and magnesium which
helps me to fill up my absolute best all
day also they have a no BS no questions
asked refund policy so you can buy it
and try it for an unlimited amount of
time and if you do not like it they'll
give you your money back and you don't
even need to return the box that's how
confident they are that you love it head
to drink
lmnt.com modern wisdom to get a free
sample pack of all eight flavors with
your first box that's drink lmnt.com
modern wisdom
projecting yourself forward to see
what are the consequences of failing
what are the consequences of stopping
yep is about as powerful of a motivation
strategy as I can think of you know
because what you're doing is you're
trying to optimize right now to stop the
discomfort that's right but what you're
going to pay for that in is shame and
guilt and regret long term that's right
so what you need to be able to do is
bundle all of that up that is as yet
unfelt but will last for way way way
longer you know the future is much
longer than now that's right the future
is going to extend out up until the day
that you die and the now is just for now
and even 130 hours is just 130 hours
that's right and you get to look back
and you look back with Pride and Glory
why'd you look back with shame and guilt
that's it that's that's the one second
you just summarized it right there and
most people feel those one seconds
and then that one second leads to 20
years 30 years 40 Years of [ __ ] I have
people who have been through training
with me Ranger schools SEAL training Air
Force training and I get calls from them
today and they have great lives and all
they talk about is how they failed in
that one moment
and they can't even
break they can't even enjoy their life
now
because they're now warm
they're now warm there's no more
suffering
there's no more suffering for me either
and we're in the same boat now
but you're suffering and I would so
we're not suffering
but you're thinking about what you could
have been
I am exactly what I should have been
and that's where people start to lose it
because now I I realize that in that one
second I go through all that I know how
it's going to feel because I failed so
many times before
failure is the ultimate thing man I
failed so many times before that's why I
look at failure anymore it's failure I
look as my first second and third
attempt
so that's what that's all about man well
I mean he went back to go and do Moab
again a second time right which is your
second attempt that's right
had you banged your knee up it was
pretty bad in between the first and the
second one it was pretty bad way before
either one of them uh-huh yeah yeah it
was it's been jacked up now for about 20
years I've seen some gnarly photos of it
recently it looks yeah interesting yeah
so all those miles I've run on this
thing is it's uh it's been a lot of uh
it's been a lot of gut checks
so you go back you do Moab a second time
yep and then you turn your ass into like
a hamburger or something as well so it's
not just the knee it's the ass as well
now yeah so at Mile 201
we have a good video of it matter of
fact
Jennifer is like there's some people up
there so at so 201 is a spot where I was
really finished in the first Moab
so that was a
um it was a way market checkpoint yeah
the second time so Jennifer is extremely
happy right now because I'm there yes
and she knows I'm doing well now I'm
doing good we're gonna get through this
and so she's videoing me as I'm coming
up this climb on this road and she goes
there's some people up here who want to
meet you you're doing so amazing I said
my ass is [ __ ] up you need to get the
[ __ ] Desitin cream and it's literally
for like 20 [ __ ] miles
that like people don't get it man when
you get raw like that bro
and you're walking because you the
chafing of my ass it was hamburger meat
and I'm like so she's all [ __ ] happy
and [ __ ] she's and I just look at her
and I'm gonna put the video up on social
media because it's but she's a [ __ ]
Trooper bro hang on so could she was a
leakage oh yeah that was on the video
from behind
so my shorts were absolutely raw dogged
yeah so when you pull them down it's
just blood
and so she goes in the bathroom because
she didn't know what she was gonna see
she has a Desitin cream she walks in
there
and
I pull him down and spread them open and
I go put that [ __ ] all up in there so
she goes in for the kill and she's
putting this Destin cream all over the
[ __ ] place man and you know what
that's the funny thing about it
that's when you know you got a good
[ __ ] with you man when you're
that raw and you're that [ __ ] up and
she's just like nothing it was like
saying hey can you like put some lotion
on my back before I go lay out that's
how she was in there man getting in it
That's it man have you considered that
that might be the most traumatic event
of all of the things that you've done in
your life what you ask Jennifer to do
that day no not at all she did worse
so that Leadville chapter when I talk
about after I finished
and then the ultra raveling or
unraveling had begun when I lay down so
oh that was on the duvet and you didn't
know the word duvet yeah I know what the
[ __ ] dude
blanket man okay yeah fair enough count
from the streets we call them blankets
okay anything that you wrap up is a
[ __ ] blanket cool
so I'm laying on the duvet
and she's all [ __ ] like about her
damn ratings that [ __ ] the Airbnb
[ __ ] and I'm really like hey I'm about
to [ __ ] because it's not your place no
okay no right yes I can see that scene
is uh is is was was bad but once again
like a crime scene it's yes it was a
crime scene so you've done all of this
stuff right you've done the seal
selection week three times strapping the
legs up so that you can run a bad water
Ultra race the Asperger's everything yes
of all of the physical Pursuits that
you've endured which has been the most
painful by far by far
my first hundred my race
by far this 2019 Moab the one that ID
enough but still finished that's up
there
but when you are
um so I guess you're you're not prepared
to run 100 miles
and you take it for granted
and you didn't do any training at all
and you had the right nutrition
and off a whim
like literally like you know what I want
to raise money for a foundation that's
how that happened so I don't know if you
know a story or not but basically I'm
sitting there and the Lone Survivor
incident happened with a bunch of you
know some seals died I want to raise
money for him I went to training with
most these guys
so I had the bright idea to uh raise
money you know I wasn't gonna do a hot
dog or hamburger sale I was gonna do
something that people would be attracted
to so I Googled the world's toughest
events
and where it comes up is this race
called the bad water 135. it's 135 mile
race through Death Valley in the
summertime
now I had no idea about ultra running I
know what the [ __ ] ultra running was but
when I heard so when I saw 135 miles
I automatically assumed it was a stage
race where you ran like maybe 10 15
miles bed down and you got next morning
did it so when I call the race director
up Chris Kaufman I'm like hey I would
like to do this race to raise money for
a foundation he goes have you ever run
100 miles
and I was like like in in a week or like
like were you talking about he goes no
like in 24 hours because that's what you
got to do to qualify and I was like is
that even is that even possible like I I
no so anyway
he goes no you can't get in my race
unless you qualify
and I call him up on a Wednesday
and that Saturday and I was a
bodybuilder at the time I did cardio 20
minutes a week on the elliptical trainer
every Sunday
he goes yeah Saturday you're in San
Diego Saturday is a 24-hour race where
you run around a one mile track for 24
hours and if you can get 100 miles
I'll consider you in my race
so I'll go sign up for this race
and the first 70 miles I'm doing pretty
good
and then I hadn't sat down I was uh had
to go in the bathroom I was eating I was
drinking mild Plex and Rich crackers I
was you know eating Rich crackers Elite
nutrition yeah elite elite high quality
nutrition
so what happens when you're that
ignorant
and you go out to do this race and you
sit down in the chair your body's done
so I'm sitting there and when you sit
down for the first time in over 12 hours
your body's now going through some
metamorphosis
like go [ __ ] at home go go to a doctor
get some help
but I'm sitting there and I have this
urge to go to the bathroom
and there's a porta potty for me that
[ __ ] wall but I can't get up because
my blood pressure's all messed up from
my great nutrition that was on and so I
can't stand up
so I look at my ex-wife and I literally
say I want to [ __ ] on myself right now
so I sit there and I'm [ __ ] up my
back and I'm peeing blood down my leg
and I have 30 miles to go
and I end up finding a way
to get through that 30 miles and when I
got done with that race
it's the worst pain
I can ever even I can't even describe
the pain of that last 30 miles to
anybody no one it's very hard whole body
whole body
um so when it ended I I I'm literally
dizzy going up my stairs to get to my
house I'm literally I have my arms
wrapped around her going up the stairs
and every flight of stairs I got I have
to lay down because I can't stay upright
for too long or I'll pass out so I
finally get in the house and I get in
the house I'm once again on the floor
I'm in the kitchen on the floor just
laying there I finally make it to the
bathroom
into the tub I get rolled in the tub and
she puts the water on me I'm just laying
there with the water coming on me
and what I pee out looks like Coca-Cola
and I'm laying there in the worst pain
of my entire life
I'm shaking I'm jacked up
and all I could think about was
I can't believe what I just done
because when you get to 70 miles of a
race and you felt the way I did
it's to me it was humanly impossible
to even think about going 30 more miles
in that shape and once you do it what
what came over me when that shower hit
me and the reality hit that
I spent 100 more miles
in that last 31 miles was something that
I can't even describe to people
and she's like we gotta get to the
hospital
so at the time my mom was seeing this
doctor and he was like you know so so
she's describing to my mom I'm going
through he's like you gotta get in the
hospital now
and I just said just just shut up
and let me enjoy this pain
I don't want anything to numb it I don't
want anything right now because what I
had done was I just in my mind
and people will take this wrong and take
as long as you want to I don't really
care I had just climbed a mental wall
that was amazing and I didn't want
anybody to take that pain away from me
at that point because I was that was all
confirmation it seems like I've heard
you tell that story a number of times
it's amazing
did that set the tone or the Rhythm for
what you wanted to try and Achieve and
feel again each time this you're pushing
further there's more difficulty I never
want to feel it again
I never want to feel it again but what
it did was it showed me what is possible
and that's what set the new stage for me
that's when I realized oh man I've
really been underachieving my entire
life I'm not saying that you have to go
to that place because that place is a
dangerous dangerous place that
borderline rhabdo hot everything
it was all that yeah but you know
you don't want to go there but it taught
me what is possible so from that 19-hour
lesson
for the best biggest lesson in my life
it taught me like okay
I got it check
tell me about this mixed type of hate
that you've made
so what started happening is as you get
bigger as you get more successful
you open the door for people to critique
every [ __ ] thing you do and most of
the people who are critiquing you
usually aren't Where You Are
and all their critiquing comes from
people who are really at a low level of
life which is sad but what we do
people who are on the upper level
hearing the haters at the lower level
like I said you'll never meet a hater
doing better than you
true statement
I started having fun with it
so I'll go through the comments While
most people don't go through comments I
go through them intentionally look for
the bad ones
and why I'll block and delete you
because the people on my page don't need
that negative energy
I'm blocking deletes you but I take a
snapshot
on my phone and I put it in the archive
so what happens is there's days where
I'm like you know what I really don't
want to do this today
and I'm like oh hang on
so I started making these mixtapes with
all of these hate messages
about people talking [ __ ]
and it became such a source of fuel that
it was amazing because I know why you
hate me you hate me because you're
probably in the bed right now you're
probably an underachiever you're
probably somebody who doesn't want to do
anything with your life
so I make you question everything about
yourself so I'm going to continue making
you question yourself
by coming out here and being even more
successful so I listen to that while I
run
I sometimes played in the house
and it sometimes gets on Jennifer's
[ __ ] nerves because I'm sitting there
listening to somebody talking mad [ __ ]
on the loop about me and she's like why
do you do this [ __ ] it's half comical
it is half um it's half inspiring I'm
actually inspired by it I've heard you
say previously that listening to music
while you train is cheating so what
you're telling me is that the Silence of
your own dark thoughts isn't enough of a
soundtrack and you've had to crowd
Source insults from the internet
self-narrate it yep and then play it to
yourself while you train that's it I do
that sometimes yes yes have you got your
phone on you right now I want to hear it
no I I don't travel with my phone oh
yeah my phone does not go with me
anywhere why is that
once again man like right now I'm with
you
a lot of times people are in
conversations or they're somewhere
elsewhere you may think they're with you
but they're not that phone is the
biggest distraction in the world
with the time so when it comes time for
the phone I'm on the phone we're not I
don't use it I'm all about being present
where I'm at so that's why that phone
right now you know no we do have it it's
in your it's silenced it's off so I do
have my phone right now but but usually
I don't take anywhere I go okay so while
you're listening to the
self-narrated insults of random people
on the internet that you don't like
right what are you thinking of while
you're listening to that while you're
working out or while you're walking
around the house
how'd that back in the day when I was
sometimes getting bullied or in a dark
place uh sometimes that would have
bothered me
how I would want to
clap back I I would want to be on there
all day explaining myself to people and
how now I'm in a place now where I can
hear it
and I can actually enjoy it I can
actually know where it's coming from
I've studied it so I don't just like
listen to it and like make fun of it I
actually study it because I was once
that negative person I was once that
person who saw someone successful
and didn't see how can I get there
I was like oh [ __ ] that they're probably
cheating or they're probably doing this
I was I was that negative person because
I wasn't there and I didn't want to work
to get there
so these people who hate on people I've
studied them
and I've gained a lot of Knowledge from
them because I gained a lot of knowledge
for myself when I was in that dark place
so it's almost like reflecting an older
version of you back to yourself 100 I
had this idea
um uh called the reverse role model so
in a lot of places people might grow up
and not have good Role Models around
them you know like it would be great if
I had someone that was my hero that
could tell me how to be x uh good in
school well with work fantastic in
relationships whatever it might be
and a lot of people don't grow up with
that right and what I realized was
because that was me in in part from
where I was from but I realized there
was a lot of people that I got to see
that were like the sort of person I
didn't want to be like right and that
was the reverse role model so I could
look around I could say I really don't
want his relationship with his wife and
I hate the way that he is using alcohol
to get over the problems in his life he
doesn't have any Integrity or tell the
truth she is a liar and a backstabber
and a gossip
and the thing is that you can actually
achieve a lot of success in life by
avoiding failure like most success in
life actually is avoiding failure yes
you need to be able to be competent But
first you need to not get out of the
race that's the one second decision
right you need to not lose before you
can win right and the reverse role model
is you weaving your way through a
selection of people that you don't want
to be like and I think that you can get
an awfully long way just by doing that I
did that my entire life I had the
ultimate blueprint by watching my family
I was the youngest kid
so the youngest kid has the total
advantage
you know you may get picked on you may
get bullied with everybody but you sit
back and exactly what you said I sat
back and watched my dad definitely don't
want to do that
my mom my brother whoever it may be
I sat back and I paid attention to
everything around me and it was the
ultimate blueprint to how to live life
not to live life how not to live life is
I watched people do [ __ ] I said uh
I don't want to be like that
I like what you said about how
the criticism that you see from people
is coming from a very unique place
I think if you got to see the inner
texture of the people who don't like use
existence you'd feel more pity than
anger for the most part I think you'd
pity them yes
um and that's a realization that's taken
a long time
for me to to come up with because
everybody else feels or to me always
seems like everyone else has got it
together because I get to see only what
you choose to say only what I'm around
you doing that I get to see whereas I
get to observe my own
inefficiency and foibles 10 000 times a
second right I get to watch the texture
of my own mind be completely
unresponsive and useless I see every
single
um prideful decision every single lie
that I tell myself every single time I
make a promise and don't keep it I don't
get to see that from everyone so I'd
always presume because of this asymmetry
that everybody else had it sorted and I
didn't and it also made me think that
everybody else's opinion was this
perfectly balanced
well-researched beautifully it was it
was they had they had me nailed down to
a t what they were telling me was the
truth they could see something in me
that I couldn't right
and after a little bit of time and a
good bit of building up of
self-confidence I realized that that's
not the case no I have pity in a lot of
people
I do
um I used to get angry about it like
there was this guy I talked about it on
on Rogan this guy from so Team Six
who went out there when I became started
becoming more famous he went out there
and just tried to destroy me
try to literally destroy me talked about
how you know he's totally lied totally
lied had to get a lawyer against him all
kind of [ __ ]
and I was getting ready to Sue this guy
I had a great I was going to sue him
because he literally tried to destroy my
character my reputation went out there
in this lightest ass off
and I thought to myself
it's about two months into it I stepped
back and I started feeling sorry for
this guy
like really sorry for him I was gonna
pull the trigger assume and I said I'm
not gonna Sue this guy
I said for you to be
this person who comes on and lies and
tries to literally tear down
everything I've worked for
you are in a very very bad place coming
to find out he was
in a very bad mental place so I get what
you're saying I've learned to study
people before I react
because there's no successful person in
the world who's in a good headspace
that's going to ever attack anyone in
that kind of manner there's always going
to be something wrong with them so you
gotta always dive a little deeper before
you get your feelings hurt before you
get your feelings hurt by that bully at
school or that boss at work
take time take that one second to pull
back and study them
because most people were in good places
they don't they don't care about what
you're doing they don't care about what
you're doing they'll try to destroy you
they actually will try to build you up
versus destroy who you are as a person
so that's where I'm at now in life is
most people who do that doing a very
dark dark place I've got a ton more to
talk to Goggins about but first I need
to tell you about ag-1 you are not
eating enough fruit and vegetables in
your diet and you know it this is going
to help I've replaced a ton of
multivitamins that I was taking every
single day with one scoop from athletic
greens it covers all of my nutritional
bases it means that I feel really good
I've got better energy my digestion has
improved I tried pretty much every drink
that I could find and none of them are
as comprehensive or as good tasting as
this it's got 75 vitamins minerals and
Whole Foods sourced ingredients
including a multivitamin multi-mineral
pre and probiotic green superfood blend
and more that all work together to fill
the nutritional gaps in your diet if
you're looking to make a good
Improvement to your nutrition your
health and fitness in the New Year this
is where you should start head to
athleticgreens.com wisdom to get a yours
free supply of vitamin D five free
travel packs free pots shakers and that
90-day money-back guarantee that's
athleticgreens.com
wisdom what do you think most people get
wrong about motivation
they think it's a permanent fix
they think it's something that
that is
a constant
they think that maybe once I get it I'm
gonna hold on to it
and that's the thing about that I was
telling you I always talk about
it's nothing that's permanent
nothing is permanent and a lot of times
you have to learn to perform without
motivation
you have to learn perform without
purpose you have to learn to perform a
lot of different things and that's what
people think they think I need to have
this motivation
to work out to study to be better so if
they don't have it they just don't
[ __ ] do it and that's where you fail
you have to learn to train your mind
well beyond motivation if you have
motivation that's great that's them can
lean to the fire all it takes is a
little bit of [ __ ] spark you can burn
the whole Forest up
but
motivation you have to learn to exist
without it you have to learn to be you
have to be your best self and your least
motivated
and that's the tricky part about all
that [ __ ] motivation is just a word you
have to have these different things in
your mind on where you want to go and
know that motivation is not going to get
me there
because I'm not going to always be
motivated Jaco said the exact same thing
you said that discipline needs
motivation for breakfast
and discipline is good too
but without a clear headspace there's no
discipline what do you mean
so let's say we have a circuit breaker
okay and I'm loading everything up to
one [ __ ] circuit just load it up
it's gonna [ __ ] blow
and once that thing blows man the circus
all [ __ ] up
you gotta have
each thing plugged into the right spot
like a [ __ ] crowded garage
you can't put anything in it once your
brain is crowded discipline is great
motivation is great but if you can't fit
[ __ ] in your brain because it's all
[ __ ] cluttered with [ __ ]
there's no discipline
you may have it sometimes when it fits
in that crowded garage
of your mind but you don't have the
consistency that you need to have with
your discipline so what are you talking
about here are you saying doing
self-work and reflecting on you as an
individual are you doing therapy I call
it my I call it mental zones I don't get
in too much because it'd be here all day
but basically
is you're organizing your mind so you
can put that discipline
so a lot of people talk about discipline
okay great why do you fall off the
[ __ ] wagon why can't I continue with
this routine going to the gym being
better waking up early eating the right
Foods
it's because maybe it's your kids maybe
it's your wife maybe it's your job and
it's all just stuffed in your [ __ ]
brain you don't have it
compartmentalized and organized in these
nice shelves like you look in the garage
it's all [ __ ] a nice organized
militant garage hey where are my
dumbbells right there
a lot of people whose brain Hey where's
my demos uh let me look they're [ __ ]
throwing [ __ ] they're looking through
toads they're all [ __ ] up
so where am I gonna put discipline
in that mind if I can't find other [ __ ]
you gotta be able to find all these
different things in your mind oh I can
put discipline right there
I can put consistency right there I can
put all these things right there in that
spot so that's what I'm talking about if
your life is not organized
in your life being
everything around you
because it takes one little [ __ ] up
piece of an outside interference to
clutter your whole mind
because it's on such a knife edge that's
right and people don't get that your
mind has to always be clear that's why
that's why I meditate two hours every
single night
because I refresh I reorganize the
garage which is my mind every night so
then disciplines in there organization
everything is in this right spot so if I
wake up I'm ready to go what does a
morning look like for you at the moment
if you've got a routine of some kind yes
I run every single morning
so that's time you up when are you
waking up I'm up about five five thirty
so every morning it starts with the Run
and that's because that's the one thing
I hate to do more than anything in the
world
so that's like my cup of coffee
and I'm all about armoring yourself
so the second you leave your house
and the second you open your phone the
second you do any of that [ __ ] you are
now letting in poison in cancer
so I make sure a lot of things you can't
avoid so as I get up I start to armor
plate my mind and body like a person's
going to war you put your body armor on
that's what I'm doing on that run
I'm waking up and I'm giving myself all
this armor so when I come out in the
world now look at that phone I'm ready
I'm not waking up late I'm not rushing
around I'm not disorganized because I
know I'm gonna get hit in the [ __ ]
mouth there's a there's an art to
getting hit in the [ __ ] mouth
and that is why these things are
important you have to wake up and you
have to give yourself belief you have to
give yourself confidence that it starts
with that run
so after the run
I come home I eat something small how
long's the Run typically at the moment
nowhere Under 12 miles
so 12 miles is the minimum and what are
you getting that done in how long it
depends right now I'm running a heart
rate so I'm doing it like 8 15s 8 30s
because I'm retraining right now because
is that zone two for you zone two yeah
because of the leg surgery I had so I'm
going back starting from scratch so
anywhere from about an hour 30 to two
hours I run every day
so so you're fasted on the morning oops
straight out straight out 90 minutes to
two hours of running back eat and I'm in
the gym
so and then after that
um to whatever's on the plan for the day
that's how that works every day are you
still doing your stretching because
you've got two hours of every night two
hours of meditation 90 minutes to two
hours of running how long is the gym
session depends 45 to an hour and a half
okay
stretching meditation run eat
Jim
what is that my mission Jennifer
oh yeah yeah forget about that you cycle
as well yeah how long are you cycling it
just depends I do stationary bike right
now a lot what are you using is it like
a what bike or something similar yeah
something similar so I put my bike on a
uh like trainer and I cycle yep at least
three or four days a week I'll do that
so
that's your day there's no there's there
is no room for anything else
yeah there is a lot of room so there's
24 hours and I use it all pretty pretty
well how how's your sleep what's your
sleep like it's really good okay eight
hours something like that seven eight
hours yeah but you need to with this
sort of volume seven eight hours and
you're still doing your stretching stuff
every night
so you've got a four hour block
basically of stretching and meditation
that's all in one block you combine the
two right yeah that's all in one block
cool
yep that's one hell of a day it is and
it's been like that for
seven years but going back to what you
said before about needing to cap success
you wouldn't be able to fit well even
one tenth of that in exactly if you were
chasing down exactly yep that's exactly
it so if all that's [ __ ] up that's why
I got a cap success because I can't put
that in do and and that's my growth
factor
so you know that's that's my human
growth factor you said before about
um how you build up self-esteem and
confidence and stuff and there's this
quote from one of my friends Alex homozy
that says you don't become Confident by
shouting affirmations in the mirror but
by having a stack of undeniable proof
that you are who you say you are outwork
yourself doubt yes
that's that's nailed nailed completely
nailed yes because a lot of people will
in some of these motivational people out
here is is the funniest thing in the
world to me they'll go and say when you
wake up in the morning pound your chest
you know [ __ ] look at yourself in the
mirror and do all this [ __ ] [ __ ]
I hope it works
what works for me is that everyday
resume the things I know of accomplished
the things I know I've done real hard
work the real calluses on my mind the
real calluses on my hands
that's that's it the you don't need to
pound your chest in the mirror to [ __ ]
anymore if you have that it seems like
especially with confidence right or
self-esteem there's a relationship
between confidence and competence so
what you're looking to do is try and
have what you believe that you can do be
ahead of what you can do right you're
not looking for it to be delusional you
don't want it to to be able to believe
that you can do something like fly right
but you need to have a relationship
between the two but what people are
asking for is for their confidence to be
so far ahead of their competence that or
without having even been competent to
anything in the beginning and that's
just delusion that's fantasy right well
I believe that you have to build belief
belief is like there's an after-school
special belief where the mom says
believe in yourself and that's all great
but there's also a built belief
and the built belief is one where you
are constantly like for me I came from a
bad place How I build belief is through
the the daunting tasks
I put myself through so that's proof
positive that I can
so it correlates and that's how this
piece of [ __ ] kid I once thought I was
don't believe by saying hmm
I was in three hell weeks I went to
Ranger school I tried out for Delta
selection undeniable stack of proof that
is proof [ __ ] so whenever you
think whenever you think you can't
confidence comes from the thing that you
built
you must build belief you must build
confidence it can be like hey
um I'm Gonna Knock that [ __ ] out
you gotta look over here and say
I can knock that [ __ ] out
is belief and it's built on what you put
in to yourself another friend sent me a
message this morning knowing that we had
this this big thing that we've been
working toward for a long time today he
said uh Nietzsche said I know of no
better life purpose than to perish in
attempting the great and impossible the
fact that something seems impossible
shouldn't be a reason to not pursue it
that's exactly what makes it worth
pursuing where would the courage and
greatness be if success was certain and
there was no risk the only true failure
is shrinking away from life's challenges
you know that one also two for two no
that one also man yeah it's that um
it's not dealing with laziness and
self-doubt thing I think uh
and I do wonder how many people use the
look in the mirror pound the chest stare
into your eyes say your affirmations
don't get the results and then lose
confidence
well that's part of it a lot of it is
limited Horizons
limited Horizons are like I use me as an
example always
I came from
a small town in Indiana
where there was a handful of black
families
and
a lot of people in that town when you
come from a town of 8 000 people
it's like we had a local plant
Great Dane and like you know what I
wanna
work at Great Dane and get a house next
to my mom
that's what you know
so many of us
come from these small places in our mind
that we're not willing to think outside
of only what we've seen
our mind works in such a small
compartment
and one thing I was able to do was to
dream
many people but don't make dreams your
[ __ ] master
but I was able to dream outside those
[ __ ] Four Walls of that small town
and until you're able to really put
yourself into that dream but don't make
dreams your master that's where you
truly become what you're destined to
become what you mean don't make dreams
your master a lot of people sit back and
they dream about being
a sports figure or dream about being a
seal or dream about being an astronaut
and all it is is a [ __ ] dream
they don't put the work behind the dream
that dream has become their [ __ ]
master
when you become the master of your
[ __ ] dream is when you say I want to
go be a Navy SEAL and you say okay I'm
gonna lose 106 pounds in less than three
[ __ ] months
the dream was the one thing I thought
about and the dream was now gone now
what comes in the dream goes away and
the [ __ ] laundry list the [ __ ]
details and tasks come up gotta do this
God do this God do this gotta do this
that's when you become the master of
your dream
so a lot of people out there dreaming
Ryan holiday says talking about the
thing and doing the thing Vie for the
same resources allocate yours
appropriately that's it
that's it
that's the way it works as well that's
the way that the brain works you can
actually get these kicks of dopamine by
telling your friends about I'm going to
be a Navy SEAL I'm going to start my
training next week it's going to be
great I'm gonna feel like this feels
good it feels good to talk about that
[ __ ] man it actually makes you feel good
makes you feel proud all that [ __ ] but
guess what happens that alarm clock goes
off at 4 a.m to train
um I want to be a seal today but I don't
want to be whatever today I'll start
tomorrow and that's the usual pattern of
people's lives
that's why
I talk about clearing out the mind until
you really want to do something you're
always going to be a talker you always
get run your [ __ ] mouth
so again with the audio version of this
book you've done podcasts in between
each chapter where you're recapping
what's just happened and this time you
brought guests one of which was your
mother right and you spend a 35 minute
conversation sitting down with her and
talking about the experiences that she
had with your father and reflecting on
that right a lot of stuff you'd elected
to leave out of the first book so that
means there's been a journey that you've
gone through to get to the stage where
both you and her and collaboratively you
felt okay sharing that publicly right
like what's that process like because
your mum didn't ask for this I mean you
kind of also did you put a book out
there because you thought it was useful
and now millions and millions of people
know about you but right you know the uh
gravity field of your notorite is
starting to bring other people in as
well so what was the Journey of getting
to that stage like well it wasn't so
much me I had already laid out you know
a lot of [ __ ] about me that was you know
pretty embarrassing and can't hurt me so
for her that actually helped her out
she said wow if he had the courage to go
out there and tell people all your [ __ ]
you know and so that process was it took
about four years
of me working with my mom because you
know she was very damaged by what she
went through and so was I but I knew no
one was coming to save me so I had to go
ahead and fix my [ __ ] and she kind of
lived in a different place
but whenever it can't hurt me it started
waking her up
the hey man why do you care
why do you care so much when people
think about you what you went through
why why are you putting so much
so much on other people
and what they may say about you like
there's some stuff I talk about you know
that is pretty embarrassing for some
people
but she got to a point of life where she
was able to you know stop caring because
we all have our [ __ ]
no one like people it's so funny to me
there'll be people who are out here
commentating about people who are
[ __ ] up out here famous people are
[ __ ] up
and I don't know how they're able to do
that
when
I guarantee while your skeletons are not
being out there
if I were to open up your [ __ ] door
[ __ ] how how how are you doing
that so I know that about everybody
like people love to talk [ __ ] about
somebody and keep themselves out of it
and so we went through that journey
together and so it allowed her to come
out and say yeah [ __ ] it you know I'm a
big person who
I want to give people the confidence to
walk in the room of a million people
and none of them like you and you just
like to say [ __ ] you I'm good and walk
out with you by yourself
and you helped your mom do that as well
and now she can look at everybody and
say yeah
I [ __ ] married a [ __ ] that
choked the woman to death
I was in a bad place
I'm good with that
one of the days that you focus on a good
bit in that conversation is the day that
she decided to leave your father right
and take you into your brother with her
was there anything that you learned
about upon reflection
where both of your experiences uh opened
up a new realization to you
that that was a hard time for her and
and for me also I was ready to leave a
long time ago I was just waiting for her
to get the courage to finally leave him
and um
I don't think anything from that really
I think that's where the damage really
began
I think for her when she left it almost
her fight
went away
and it's kind of like when you run
100 miles
when you sit down your body can then say
that's exactly what I was thinking I'm
done it's exactly what I was thinking
the second she left
that the Mind said oh my God like we can
we can be human it's like PTSD yes we
can be human and we're not fighting
anymore and it just swarmed the demons
that all that fight and all that [ __ ]
was keeping away it just came and it
swallowed it swallowed her whole it also
swallowed me whole but once again like
we were talking about I got a chance to
watch her
and she set out the ultimate blueprint
on how not to be
so I had a hard time learning growing up
but I was very smart when it came to
human beings
a genius
because I lived in such hell I was
always studying people who can I trust
who can I not trust energy I got really
good with energy can I this person's
energy good is it bad so I became a
genius on human beings
so I studied people all the time
I studied all the time
she also talks about
considering taking your own life oh yeah
were you aware of that before you
started working toward this book yeah so
yeah she she talked about that a few
times with me behind closed doors
and um
I'm surprised she did it
you know there's a lot of stories that
are still Untold
that she probably will never talk about
and I'll never talk about him until she
says it's fine but um yeah it was it was
a bad it was it was a bad way so I I
gave her credit for having the strength
to say okay
I need to continue on and figure out you
know what's next for me but she says the
only reason that she didn't go through
with it is because of you and your
brother because she knew that she would
be leaving you in the hands of this
Tyrant that was going to mistreat you
even more badly now that she wasn't
around to protect you yeah which is a
it's beautiful but it's also kind of a
lot of pressure it feels like a lot of
pressure for a child to be the reason
for his mother to to still be there and
it's also a
dumbing conclusion about the state of
her life right that the only thing
stopping you from taking your own life
is these two boys but it's also
beautiful in a way
because a lot of people only have one
thing
you don't need a lot of things
sometimes only thing that kept me with
that one step forward was one thing
and so that one thing can get you to two
things to three things the four things
so that was the beautiful thing about
that is that now she's 75 and she's
retired because of that one thing
how
I mean you're having this conversation
with your mum during the production of
the audiobook
you're having a conversation which is
difficult to have in private right with
two microphones in front of you knowing
full well that this is going out to
millions of people it's going to be
scrutinized it's going to be listened to
it's going to be reflected on how
difficult is it to watch your mother
opening up about an experience which to
you was traumatic and then reopening
those wounds in front of you and talking
about that for millions of people to
hear oh it's hard
it's hard but
it's necessary
why
to be able to own your trauma
to be able to own everything about you
and look it in the eye
like there's a part in eight mile
with Eminem the very end
when this white boy you know [ __ ]
trying to make it in the rap world and
getting beat down and [ __ ]
comes from some trailer park [ __ ] and
he's like
how the [ __ ] am I going to win this rap
battle because my best friend got shot
in the foot and this dude slept with my
girl and all this [ __ ] so what he does
to take all the power from the
[ __ ] gonna rap battle his ass
he's like
I'm gonna tell you every [ __ ]
thing about me
I'm just gonna [ __ ] tell you
and that's how I feel about life
and that's how my mom now feels about
life
I'm just gonna [ __ ] tell you
everything a [ __ ] about me I'm not gonna
hide I'm not gonna do none of this [ __ ]
and it's a refreshing feeling
when you can get in front of millions of
people get an audiobook and you can go
through your [ __ ] and lay it out and you
walk away there's no more secrets
there's no more secrets like people say
oh hey Lance Armstrong you do steroids
no no no yes
well I have nothing I have nothing wrong
with Lance Armstrong anybody else
[ __ ] telling [ __ ] man
and guess what happens to the
conversation
it's over
it [ __ ] ends there's a really telling
Moment In the book I think it's my
favorite part and it's not even in this
one it's in the audiobook and it's when
it's getting quite difficult with your
mum and you offer her a root out you ask
if she wants to take a break yup she
says no yeah I'm gonna keep going
so it seems like she's got a bit of that
dog in her as well oh yeah she had to
yeah she had to one thing that when you
grow up the way we kind of grew up
together so I look at it when you grow
up when she had she had 28 and my
brother at 24. so um about that you know
we grew up together and you got to have
a dog in you
you have to have a dog in you man and so
you have to have it like my grandfather
caught it a stiff upper lip
you better have a stiff upper lip so you
know yeah she has some dog in her she
has some dog in there she has to there's
no other way to make it out here
I mean you can't just always be
you know head down in the sand
you gotta learn to pick yourself up on
your own a lot of times these fights and
these battles you gotta be your own
[ __ ] coach you gotta be your own
motivator and she had to do that several
times in her life given all of this
trauma that you go through
why would you choose to go back and see
this Tyrant of a father
for one last time it was the only way
for me to move forward
so like a lot of times
if your back is hurting it may not be
your [ __ ] back
it may be something else in your bias
making your back hurt
for me
I'm like man why can I get past this
[ __ ] hurdle
it's like I said I'm always examining
myself every day
what is it what is it
well there's only one thing you haven't
examined yet
and it's going back to the Beast going
back to the demon so when I went back to
him I realized that that was the
unsolved mystery
was I hadn't looked at man the eye one
more time
like how I studied the that Navy SEAL
talking [ __ ] and lying
I got it from this part right here in
the book
I went and I didn't see him anymore as
this Beast
I started doing research on him found
out that his dad used to beat him really
bad so my his dad
would put him in front of a furnace
open the furnace up with the Flames
coming out
and put them right in front of it
having bare butt naked
and he would whip the [ __ ] out of him
and the whole idea of that is if you
move you're going to get burned
so stay right here and take your [ __ ]
beating
so what happened with him
those demons from his father went to my
father
and he tried to transfer him over to me
I had to understand who my father was
understand where he came from understand
why were you so [ __ ] brutal to us
I got my answers
took those answers it made myself better
from the answers about him
and so that's why it was necessary for
me to go back not I was looking for an
apology
so then maybe I could just go be a loser
and understand that you [ __ ] me up why
would the apology make you a loser
it would make no it would make me feel
Vindicated Justified yes like man you
you did this to me
I can go be a loser now my failings are
okay this okay yep because you did this
so I was looking for that and when I
went there I I realized because this
voice and he was saying it's not your
dad's fault
and I'm like ah man because his voice
over here always said it's your dad's
fault this other voice started tuning in
was loud started getting louder the more
I drove to Buffalo was saying
you get to face a lot of [ __ ] young man
you got a long journey ahead of you
because you're gonna find out that while
your dad did a lot of [ __ ] to you
you're gonna have to [ __ ] make it on
your own
and the voice got louder and louder and
louder and by time I got to that door
and by time I was leaving that house
instead of me feeling sorry for myself
I started to doing live autopsy
because a lot of people
when you die
they figure out why you died they figure
out how you died
in the autopsy
but we never do a live autopsy to figure
out why we're dying while we are alive
and I was dying I was living every day
but I was really dead
and so I figured it out and once I
figured it out I was able to
reborn I was able to be reborn
what we see is this pattern of
generational trauma your grandfather to
your father your father to you father to
son just being passed on passed on
passed on
is this part of your mission to be a
circuit breaker to be a dam to stop this
Trauma from moving forward into the Next
Generation 100 but with people I'm
trying to build people up
I'm trying to armor their mind I'm
trying to get them the belief because
this world we live in is tough
it's tough it will beat you down the
world and the life that we live in is
the ultimate competitor it will try to
take you out it will it will find your
weakness
and it will [ __ ] just Hammer you it's
like a personal cause a hundred percent
so if I can help you
build belief build confidence to the
point where
nothing can hurt you because you know
exactly who you are you've faced your
demons
you've you've been able to go on an
audiobook in your mind maybe you didn't
write a book but in your mind you were
able to hear all your past traumas
you're able to listen to them
you're able to [ __ ] say okay now I
can now talk to people about what I went
through I'm no longer embarrassed I'm no
longer ashamed being ashamed is one of
the biggest things that kill people
nowadays in their minds kill them from
moving forward I'm ashamed of myself
don't ever be ashamed of anything you've
done in your life face it fix it make it
better
we are humans
but then again if you always think that
we're humans
you will always just be a human and
always make the same [ __ ] mistakes
you must take this knowledge that you
learned from all this [ __ ] is knowledge
so I'm just trying to give people that
strength to go in the archives of your
life
because
while you're probably [ __ ] up is
probably something happened to you in
your life go through the archives dig it
up
study it
and then use it for yourself that's
that's the main purpose for me right now
have you considered what you would be
like as a father
yeah I actually have a daughter right
now
yeah no way I didn't know yeah
I have a daughter right now but that
being said
I'm an open honest person
when you meet people at a young age so I
had a kid at a young age when I was in
the worst possible place in my life so
when you're in a bad place
you're not going to meet a Kish
you're going to meet a person that's
very similar to who you are at that time
and then you bring a child into this
world and as you start to move up in
this world and get better and you
realize I need to get better
you try to pull that person along with
you
a lot of times they don't want to come
where you're going
and it creates a bad environment
so
that's what that is right now
talking about my daughter's 21 years old
though wow yeah I'm glad to hear that I
think I I think that uh
it would be
all of the learnings and stuff that
you've been through as a father as a son
as a grandson
um it makes sense to me that that would
have been a
something that could have been passed
out so thinking about
uh trauma and stuff that you go through
in your past
um it's um throughout most of school for
me I was pretty isolated only child uh
pretty unpopular in school and the main
issue that I had was
it wasn't bullying it was isolation I
think it was being lonely right um and
that was
primarily what was causing me to be sad
throughout school right so I did this
interview for the BBC about
six months ago and uh in it I talk about
I haven't opened up that much about
bullying and I need to do it more and it
is you know even from watching you go
through opening up about your traumas is
inspiring uh so I do this interview for
the BBC and I mentioned a little bit
about bullying in school and
so what I know as you mentioned it
I haven't got around to it yet I I maybe
still feel like it
detracts from the man that I want to be
the masculine man the
um respected podcaster that it's somehow
undermines me as a person that it makes
me weaker which is obviously what was
you know part of the bullying's purpose
in school to be able to do precisely
that right so I do this interview for
the BBC and I mentioned in two
paragraphs or something but millions of
people see this article uh and I get
back one day and in my Instagram message
requests is this message from a guy and
I kind of recognize his name but not not
fully and I don't know whether you know
but there's like a character limit in
Instagram so and this is five character
limit messages long with multiple
paragraphs within each of them right so
I open it up uh and this guy says uh hi
Chris you might not remember me but we
went to school together uh I bullied you
my daughter is four and she's about to
go to school and given that she's about
to go to school me and my wife have been
discussing about the kind of child that
we want her to be and that caused me to
reflect on my time that I spent in
school
I saw I've been thinking about messaging
you for a while I've been considering
talking to you because I really felt
like I needed to because I felt ashamed
of the way that I treated you in school
and I knew that it had hurt you
uh and then I saw this article from the
BBC and I just had to reach out and
I've been sleepless nights speaking to
the wife tears and all the rest of it uh
and that's why I just said I'm sorry I'm
very sorry for what I did
um I wanted to let you know that my
daughter
is going to be raised in a way that will
never treat anybody like that again
um I don't expect you to forgive me I
don't even know if you'll see this
message I'm happy to see that you seem
to be happy
um
but I needed to get it off my chest
right
I'm like [ __ ] totally taken about it
like wasn't prepared for this I have
come back in from the gym or something
and I'm sat reading this message like
[ __ ] hell that's heavy so I go back
through and I think well how do I feel
about this how do I feel about this
person how do I feel about my experience
right
um because it was so formative right
shaped so much of the way that I see
myself the way that I see the world I
had to deprogram
so much of the patterns that I'd learned
right through that time
um my desire for validation from other
people right my needs to be liked my
constant vigilance my ambient anxiety
that was always looking for what was
going on my concern of being laughed out
yep my adamant nature that everybody was
um able to judge something about me that
I didn't know about myself yeah
but this guy you'd like
fully fully opened up to me and I
thought well you know
it was beautiful it was a beautiful
message
um so I replied to him and I said hey
man um
I'd very much appreciate you reaching
out I think it's an incredibly Brave
thing to do
and
if
me going through what I went through and
then the pain and discomfort and such
and your subsequent suffering of
reflecting on what you did
if that has led to a world in which your
daughter
will be the sort of person who will
behave in a manner that's going to make
the world a better place going forward
I think that's a price that's worth
paying that's awesome man
that's that's a great story
that's a great story and
you're the you're the expert on it
that's why you should talk about
bullying I know yeah you're the expert
and that's why I do it
you know um that's why I become I've
I've become so vulnerable because all
that knowledge you gain because now you
are successful
and there's so many people who are
getting bullied in so many ways
that you know
you just show them that there's a path
but the path is really like I talk about
studying the bully
that's the path
studying the bully we have attempted to
become a bully
never I'm always like I said like I told
you before this started I wanted to be a
priest
I want to be a priest you know and uh
could you imagine one of those sermons
oh it'd be sick because I would cuss
because I would I would definitely cuss
praise the Lord [ __ ] that's it
I would definitely cuss I would
definitely cuss man because that's
that's the world
and there's a lot of people if I hear
this like oh my God that's this is oh my
God let me close my hair
you know this
the world's tough
the world's tough
and
when you come up the way I came up the
only way I can [ __ ] describe
something sometimes is say [ __ ] a
[ __ ] because that's how dark this
[ __ ] was
and I can't make it flowery I can't make
it PG like oh I want my kids to like I
have a clean edition of this book
oh you have a non-explicit version yes
because people like I want my I want my
kid to read your book but you but you
cuss so much I can't I imagine it's
about half the size yes it's very small
yes so
so the funny thing about it is like how
long are you going to
shelter your child
from a world that's evil as [ __ ]
that's going to come at you
it's going to come at you whether you've
been bullied or not there's going to
come a time
where it's going to come at you and it's
gonna be a lot worse than [ __ ] or
[ __ ] it's gonna be a lot worse
and so we are training kids and people
to be soft in a world that continuously
gets harder
and it doesn't it doesn't correlate like
that guy talking about the tear gas with
the seals is that necessary
I don't know but what is necessary is
you have to build a person that can
withstand the pressures of whatever
they're going to be dealing with in life
and we don't do that I'm not trying to
send a message of run 200 miles be the
best [ __ ] in the world
but be tough
you better have a part about you that's
tough a part about you that can break
down situations and get better
and break down situations very quickly
Within
some trauma in your life some
Devastation in your life because it's
going to come the devastation the trauma
is going to come and you can't allow
that to become a jersey barrier
it can't be a jersey bear it has to be
something that you can maneuver through
very quickly and move forward that takes
a lot of toughness well
unchosen suffering is going to happen
right so the only thing that you can do
is have some shows and suffering to
prepare for it it's the only thing you
can do that's the only thing you can
practice for the unchosen suffering is
have chosen suffering
do something that sucks every day
I had human on the show a few months ago
and he told me about bringing you into
his lab
and putting you in VR underwater with
sharks right
give me your experience with huberman
he's great he he knows his stuff
he knows his stuff
um yeah he's just a he's a very
knowledgeable man on what he's doing
what's being in VR with sharks like it's
nothing no no
no because one thing about me is I deal
in reality
you put me in vr's VR
it's a fake
thing
and I work in reality
I only work in reality I don't work in
fake situations so that's why I didn't
work on me
you put me in a real ocean with real
sharks
you'll get your real reaction
you put me in a room that I when you
walk in the door
and you sit down in the chair and you
put some [ __ ] on your [ __ ] face
I know I'm in a [ __ ] chair
I know I'm in a room if you get that
Psych the [ __ ] out
you need to study that more than that
you know what I'm saying yeah why are
you so sensitive why are you so sick yes
if you are on a high wire because you're
afraid of heights but you're sitting
firmly on the [ __ ] ground you need to
study the fact that you're doing
something wrong
don't study the afraid of heights study
why the [ __ ] do I know I'm on the
[ __ ] ground in a [ __ ] chair but
I'm afraid of what's on this screen
so I don't allow anything to go beyond
the truth
he said that
um obviously you didn't know this in
advance it could have been the most
lifelike VR in the history of the world
and apparently it was a group of you
guys and someone had to go first someone
had to go first you're not that good
with water not sure how you feel about
sharks but can't imagine you're a fan
um
and you were just like me me please yeah
first yeah I'm like there with
everything
because why sit back in the back
and think about let me watch you go
first
you can watch me go first
is there anything that you'd like to
study with heberman would there be any
like cool tests is there anything that
you've been thinking about to do with
performance or anything like that at the
moment
no you've just got your own mental lab
you're doing everything it's a lab every
everything I need is in my mental lab
everything because I'm in constant study
of myself
that's and I know what needs to be
conquered because I'm constantly going
through
what I don't like what I'm not
comfortable with you know like
I'm I know
and only I can fix these problems
because I have to face these problems so
I have a rolling
a rolling log of what needs to happen so
I'm I'm really good at being accountable
about okay
you need to be better here you need to
be better here you need to overcome this
overcome that and I
do a good job of doing that you talk
about performance without a purpose
what's that
so like for instance let's say you have
no races let's say you have no classes
no nothing you have there's no purpose
in your life you know people need to
have purpose to get up they need purpose
to perform
you need to get to a point in your life
where there's nothing on the docket
there is no 5K there's no there's no um
I'm gonna get into school to be this or
that and still perform to the highest
level
because what people don't get is one day
that thing's gonna come up
and if you're not constantly performing
without purpose you're not going to be
ready when a time comes
it's this magical thing purpose that
we're all looking for
but what's funny about it all is that we
need these things to perform
but we don't take a second to realize
the purpose is always there
the purpose never leaves us
because the very purpose is you
you are always the purpose there may be
another purpose like being a seal or
going to college or whatever but the
main purpose in life is you
so if you wake up in the morning and you
don't want to do something
you don't care enough about yourself
and that's what you need to really
research is man why am I not doing this
for myself because that is that is the
number one purpose in life
is to better oneself
so that's the only purpose I [ __ ]
need so the reason I give up every day
even though there's no race or there's
no school there's nothing in front of me
is because I have pride in myself
but where do you go to you wake up on a
morning it's cold it's wet it's dark
you've got no cartilage in your knee
you've got shitty shots whatever it is
that's the issue today keep talking
you've got these problems right I need
you to keep talking about what you were
just saying it's warm on the couch your
message says stay stay in bed it's comfy
it's cozy you've got work later on you
had an argument last night you're
slightly hungover because I know every
[ __ ] ain't gonna do what I'm
gonna do
so this is how you level up
that's how you level up I know there's a
whole bunch of people with that right
there that fires me up
that makes me [ __ ] happy which you
just said that brings joy to my life
right there why because I know there's
so many people that have the ability
and just refuse to get off that couch
refuse to study a few more hours refuse
to go deeper to go further
and that's where I gained the advantage
it's so easy to be great nowadays my
friend because most people are weak
most people don't want to go to that
extra mile most people don't want to
find that extra because it sucks it's
miserable it's lonely you talk about
that you were kind of you know Lonely by
yourself
I was the same way
And That Used To Hurt Me growing up
now I [ __ ] thrive in that [ __ ] that's
the only place to be well that was one
of the things that
is so surprising about
growing up through difficulty you know
so loneliness is one example right
growing up as a lonely kid
what you realize is a lot of the things
that you
feared or hated or embarrassed about as
a child
end up being the Genesis of the things
that you're most proud about as an adult
so the fact that you can work and thrive
in solitude gives you the opportunity to
be able to move to America and start a
podcast or decide to do uh hell week
three times in a row or it doesn't
matter how long or dark the courses
you're just gonna stay
the fact that you were uh forced to be
vigilant and to assess people to work
out what's going on
when you became an adult allows you to
detect the vibe and the energy of
whoever it is that you're speaking with
and know that this person's someone that
I want to hang with in this person
somebody that I don't right all of the
things in fact I would go as far as to
say there's not one thing in my life
that I see as a
pure advantage that doesn't have a dark
side to it that came about at some other
point as well right so one of the
reasons that I spent so much time as a
kid in my bedroom listening to audio
tapes because I didn't have anyone to
play with right only child a little bit
sort of unpopular so I'd be in my
bedroom listening to audio tapes we go
to the library every two weeks and we
take the tapes back and we get new tapes
and I bring them and listen to them
again right but you roll the clock
forward 20 years and what's the 2023
version of an audio tape it's a podcast
podcast
a lot of the things that you love and
value in yourself
in adulthood are the light side of
something that you were ashamed fearful
disgusted by when you were younger yeah
I mean I think that comes from
overcoming
a lot of people you know wonder how did
you become this how do you become so
vulnerable how do you how are you doing
a podcast now and you were this kid
you overcame things
you fought them and now this is what
happens this is on the other side of
overcoming
it becomes you become very very powerful
when you overcome yourself
all those things you once covered from
you're afraid of when you face him eye
to eye every day you know I become
a person who has a great podcast
let's say that there's someone listening
who resonates with what you're talking
about you know they've been through
trauma they've been through hard times
but they keep breaking promises to
themselves and they're struggling to get
off the couch and they're having a pity
party
how can they stop feeling sorry for
themselves
that's a difficult one
because you have to want it
you have to want to be better
and it starts off with you have to have
pride in yourself
you you have to have pride in yourself
you have to have there's something about
you whether it's your last name whether
it's
just the smallest thing
you have to be proud of yourself if you
have no prior to yourself I can't give
it to you because you're always going to
compromise you're always going to fold
always I'm very proud of myself that's
why when people said
you know where you can do better than
can't hurt me
Roger that we'll [ __ ] see it's that
Pride that wakes you up now that's about
bad Pride
I I'm a the attention to detail for the
human being I want to do I call this
thing like I want to be the standard
I want to be that guy like every place I
went in the military there was this
ethos
about how this place is how we're going
to live how we're going to represent
ourselves and I walked around and I saw
that most people didn't live up to that
ethos
like if you go to
whatever whatever company they they had
this mission statement on how we want to
run our company
I made one for myself
on how I want to be
and that is why if people can make up a
mission statement in ethos in which they
want to live by
and every morning you wake up you hold
yourself accountable to that mission not
a company is your own make up your own
mission statement what do you want to be
in life and once you do that now you can
work with somebody to get better you can
work with yourself to get better but
until you know what you want to stand
for
you will always just be sitting down
you'll never stand for anything what's
that quote if you don't stand for uh
something you'll fall for everything
that's it it's a true statement
in the book you talk about uh Roger that
there being two types of Roger that I
absolutely adore the second type
uh received orders given expect results
that's it so cool above and beyond more
than was expected that's right to the
ladder that's Roger that that is for me
what Roger that means received orders
given yep expect results expect results
that's right so [ __ ] dope that is it
that is it and when you hear that from
somebody who gets it you know it because
you can look in their eyes
you feel that energy man it connects
immediately they're out here to get a
job done Roger that
so
it started the book or at least the
start of the audiobook you've got a few
different intros right uh Rogan yep your
mum and The Rock right uh slightly odd
Trifecta but
very I do think it works so obviously
your time Rogan's had you on now the
third time that you've been on what have
you learned since being friends with him
he's a very singular individual you know
what one thing about him is that he's
made it he's all about everybody else
making it
there's one thing that he believes in is
that there's enough food enough cake for
everybody out here to eat
so there's a lot of people in this world
who don't want to see you make it
because they think you could take a
piece of their pie
that motherfucker's like look dude
pie for everybody I got 14 pies bro one
for every [ __ ] here
and so he's all about people making it
and that's something that a lot of us
can you know learn from
that people think oh I made it I'm gonna
hold on to it I'm not gonna help anybody
else out the thing is I don't even know
if he was uh something tells me I had
that philosophy before he'd even made it
yeah as he was on the come up yeah I
mean I really didn't know him that much
back then
but um the
he really is to me
the Oprah of the modern day
he's the open the modern day you know
that that guy's just has made so many
people known to the world
gotten so many messages out so yeah I
said uh I was talking to Andrew Schultz
about the same thing and he said very
similar sentiment especially he's coming
from a comedy uh angle right and if
you're going to be championed in comedy
it's super super difficult right and
what he what he said was that uh
the comedy world is so zero-some like
your gig is not my gig that's right and
the fact that you can have someone that
just gives that gift out is very rare
another friend his wife does ayurvedic
medicine so it's I'm not really too sure
what it is but she did something to do
with like tarot card reading okay and he
asked her he was about to go on Rogan's
podcast
so he asked her to do the tarot card
readings about Joe because it might give
him a little bit more insight or just be
interesting in general and the tarot
card that she pulls out might not be
Tara will be something similar the card
that she pulled out was um uh older
Warrior cross-legged sat under a tree
with his hands like that this guy did it
and he's got a weapon down next to him
weapons laid down transcended the battle
and I was like holy [ __ ] it's like I'm
not too sure I'm not too sure about
what's going on with this tarot card
reading thing but that one seems pretty
accurate it's probably perfect for him
yeah yeah
there's something about um
raising other people up as you go along
oh yeah that you know as you get a
platform as you have the opportunity to
expose other people that are almost all
of your time as a podcaster is slip
streaming of the people who have bigger
platforms and then after a while they
get to this stage where you can be that
springboard for others right some
unbelievably talented person that nobody
knows about it there you go now the
world can know about you he's done the
best at that he's the best at that
what about the rock have you ever met
him you ever trained with him never
never we just Damned and I was like I'm
gonna give you a shot in the dark you
know the guy follows me he knows about
me whatever
I was like this guy's so big man ain't
gonna [ __ ] it besides Deanna man but
then like
20 minutes hey man what's up brother
sends me a voice message
in DM been following your work man love
what you [ __ ] do blah blah blah blah
blah oh yeah no problem man I'll I'll
hook you up I'll be more in honor to
hook you up
and in the audiobook people don't know
is I left them alone I was like hey man
thank you I appreciate it I want to
bother you go back to doing the great
work that you do you're so busy
so I was in the audiobook he was like
Hey brother you want me to um
you know read what I wrote for you for
the audiobook and I was like
yeah that's great that's something I did
came about it was actually Rock's idea
for him to do the blurb so then I got
Joe Rogan and I got my mom to read the
blurbs so that came from him I wasn't
gonna put the blurbs in the audiobook
but
he was like hey man I got a studio right
here I'll blast it out send it over to
you and we'll get it done
that's a training session that the world
wants to see
I believe so I believe so
that should be part of the book tour it
could be a training a training session
between you guys talk me through what
the next phase of your life has in store
um so after this podcast I probably
won't do another one for a very long
time and I did my
book came out on the sixth it's not the
16th I did my 10 days of the book and
now it's done
and now it's going back to the lab
so now I go back go back to firefighting
go back to finding another level of
David Goggins and that's done
been quiet areas and finding more of
myself finding these these spaces
haven't you know
discovered yet my mind and I really love
that about life I love
mastering self
I love it I love it there's there's
nothing more because I know where I came
from and it's amazing that where I came
from that person could have died
that very
fat lazy unfulfilled person and with
inside that person was this person
talking to you is very freaky to me and
a lot of us have these two people that
you have greatness way over here
but you
decide to live
in this space over here because between
greatness or between this space here and
greatness there's a lot of [ __ ] work
there's so much space to fill in with
work and we just say [ __ ] it
I'll just stay over here in this space
so
I like to [ __ ] examine all these
spaces and there's there's still more
there's still more still a lot more
are you aiming to find peace at any
point
think about this
I love that question I'm glad you I'm so
glad you asked it
you know a little bit about me
when you've come from that place I talk
about to the place I am now
is not the peace you find
the peace I find and I find so much
peace in looking back at that young
David eight years old with white spots
on his face and stuttering in hair
patches falling out and I look at him
like man
there's so much peace in knowing what I
have accomplished and what I've done
so my peace may be different for others
that's why I never critique or never
judge anyone because I don't know your
story where you come from I found peace
years ago
years ago
in the battle
in the battle you find peace when you go
to war with yourself
you find a lot of peace
because you know exactly who you are
and that is where the piece has really
found for me
David you're a spectacular individual I
really really appreciate your time uh
the book is fantastic your message is
fantastic uh I can't wait to see what
you do next even if it takes five years
I appreciate it my friend thank you
thanks for having me thank you very much
for tuning in I really hope that you
enjoyed that episode with Goggins it has
been six months in the making and it was
a ton of fun if you did enjoy it then
don't forget to subscribe it really does
make a difference and press here to
watch a selection of the best clips from
the podcast over the last few months
foreign